a race to rescue hundreds of migrants in
the Mediterranean the Italian Navy and
Coast Guard launch an operation to reach
three boats of south of Calabria they
pull those on board to safety and take
them to Italian ports they are among
five thousand migrants and refugees to
reach Italy since Wednesday Rescuers say
the numbers are overwhelming the current
situation especially in the central
Mediterranean Sea the route of this sea
world is covering is absolutely chaotic
especially in the last couple of days
with our record of songs the aircraft
CO2 we for example witnessed 19 distress
cases on the 8th of March another 14 won
on the 9th of March and six uh yesterday
we also witnessed two shipwrecks one in
front of Tunisia where at least 14
firsts drowned and another one in front
of lambertusa where at least one woman
has ground
last month another boat washed up on a
beach in the Calabria region at least 76
people were killed in that accident
the victims include a young girl whose
body was only discovered on Saturday
February's shipwreck has angered the
local community thousands protested on
Saturday against the government they
accused of failing to intervene and save
migrants they say prime minister Giorgio
Maloney's plan to crack down on human
traffickers is not the answer
to demonstrate for these victims and for
all the victims of the sea I hope this
stops
it is necessary to face that migrant
issue with the creation of secure and
legal channels because hardening the
sentences of Smugglers will not stop
this phenomena
meanwhile facilities to process migrants
and refugees are at Breaking Point
Italy's defense Ministry says it's
working to transfer thousands of people
from the island of lampedusa to the
mainland officials say more than 17 000
people have arrived by sea this year
alone that's almost three times the
number for the same period last year and
with Summer approaching that number is
expected to grow
Al Jazeera